hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here coming
at you in the midst of final exams with
a bit of an exclusive so i've been
messing with the oneplus one lately
which you probably already knew if you
follow me on twitter and i've been
getting non-stop questions about it
naturally which helps a lot with the
review process so keep the questions
coming
this isn't really a full review video
that's coming later and believe me i
have a lot to say about this phone but
since i've gotten to know the phone over
the past couple of days i figured some
things are worth sharing as this is a
pretty interesting phone and for all
intents and purposes it's a cyanogen mod
phone so here are five awesome features
that i found so far from the exclusive
cyanogenmod 11s on the oneplus one
alright so the first cool thing i want
to show you guys is the camera app of
the oneplus one that would be the number
one feature so
obviously you can just tap that icon at
any time if you want to get into it or
since this is android 4.4 you can just
swipe in from the right at any time and
that'll bring up the camera app and you
notice the user interface looks really
familiar really similar to the google
camera except with its own sign engine
mod special improvements so first of all
the settings are really easy to access
you just tap that settings button and
you can immediately choose the quality
of the photos the size i went with 13
megapixels which is the max and a couple
of other things about exposure and touch
to focus that you can just swipe right
over into your video settings and there
you can choose between 1080p or 720p or
4k video time lapse video and then one
more will get you to some general
settings where you can set the power
button as a shutter but other than that
yeah it's a pretty simple quick camera
app and i've enjoyed using it taking
panoramas is really easy starting to
record a video is really easy and the
shutter is pretty fast
wherever you tap it's tap to focus and
then whenever you want to switch between
different scene modes instead of picking
them manually you can literally just
swipe between them so swiping down
will move you between the different
effects that you can apply to your image
and you get that live preview so you
don't have to guess what it'll look like
obviously you just keep swiping until
you find something you like
use that mode and take the shot and
there are a lot of them uh but if you
just want to get a clean quick shot just
go onto auto and that should be pretty
easy too all right so this next one
actually blew my mind with how easy and
simple it is because it's never really
been this easy on android devices before
there's actually a screencast app built
into the oneplus one and the cyan engine
mod rom so usually you'd have to root
your android device or go through some
crazy convoluted steps to get a halfway
decent screencast but now you can just
start the app and literally hit the
start creamcast screencast button and
now it's recording and you can record
the exact actions you take on your phone
a lot of you guys don't know but i
actually started this youtube channel
with nothing but screencasts and it's
really cool to see this on android now i
can literally go through and do app
demos and different site demos and
mobile stuff and it'll record the way i
touch the display and exactly what
happens on the screen whatever i do so
this is really useful and it's actually
a pretty decent frame rate too so i can
go through some some pretty nifty stuff
i might even try gaming on it later some
more stuff in the full review but uh
this is definitely useful and i'm glad
to see it whenever i want to stop the
recording i can just go up to the
notification bar and hit stop and it's
immediately ready to share so i can just
uh upload that to dropbox real quick and
add it into the video and show you guys
what it looks like all right so the
third awesome thing i found is another
thing that used to require being rooted
to do and that is the theme engine built
into this os so if you go into the app
drawer you'll see this theme showcase
and this will bring you to a list of
basically a store of a bunch of
different themes that you can apply now
the thing is you can have more than one
theme installed and use different themes
to affect different parts of your os so
you can have one theme that affects your
wallpapers and one theme for your fonts
and one theme for your boot animations
and your sound packs and all different
types of things here and of course when
i hit this menu button here you'll have
the two installed themes that come with
the phone so i'm gonna go ahead and
actually switch here from the hollow
default theme you can see here i have a
whole bunch of googly looking icons that
are very familiar so i'm going to go
ahead and switch
just the icons from the great freedom
pack you can see what's included in the
pack when you download it so i'm going
to pick the icons and apply the theme
and that looked pretty quick so now when
i hit home i have a new set of icons on
my home screen and i didn't have to use
an app or anything special to do that
all the apps that are built into the
icon pack are affected not everyone is
is included in this particular icon pack
but if you find one in the store that
you really like you can apply it and use
its icons or like i said it's boot
animation or whatever you want i'm going
to switch back to holo
again i was pretty quick
and i'm right back to the holo icons
pretty snazzy so the next awesome thing
that i've made a kind of a big deal
about but that not a lot of people were
noticing is that you can change between
on-screen and off-screen buttons on this
phone and a lot of people you know when
considering the perfect phone like to
decide that they they don't like on
screen buttons because it takes up
precious screen real estate so you can
switch those on and off by going into
the settings and hitting the buttons
setting and you can choose to check or
uncheck the on screen buttons so when
you turn those off you have now the menu
home and back button and you can double
tap the home button to turn the screen
off and bring up other sort of quick
actions and you can always now use these
to navigate but if you're like me and
you're used to a nexus you're coming
from a google play edition device you
can enable the on-screen nav bar and
what's even neater here is i'm used to
these rooted features where you can go
into the interface and go and scroll for
buttons and layout and you can now
choose to add or subtract buttons from
the software buttons here so i'm going
to go ahead and add a permanent search
button and lock that down and now i have
a permanent search button here in my my
software buttons at the bottom of the
phone so that's extremely useful if you
want to add a permanent menu button
there or a permanent search button like
i just did again if you don't like that
you can at any time go back in to the
interface and change it to look really
really similar to nexus just by
unlocking it and i guess removing it or
swiping it around and that's what you
have
you have the ability to change all these
crazy things that you really only got
when you were rooted or using a device
that you rooted yourself and the last
but certainly not least awesome feature
is what i like to call just the little
things the little things that cyanage
and mod has built in to this that you
may or may not enjoy or appreciate but
that they've done
and will help if you're used to using a
rooted phone or something that's had
cyanogenmod on it before here's an
example of the quick settings that you
can swipe down with two fingers you have
that plus button up here and that lets
you choose what buttons you have in the
quick settings so if i want to be able
to sleep the phone at any time with just
a single tap of a button i just add it
to the quick settings
and there it is
sleeps the phone at any time so quick
and easy stuff like that another one is
the transparent volume slider a lot of
people don't appreciate but in stock
android if you change the volume with
the volume button here that would have
an overlay over whatever you're working
on so if i'm gaming and i want to turn
down the volume real quick i don't have
anything in the way of whatever i was
just working on of course if i touch it
with my finger it becomes opaque but
when i'm just using the volume keys it
doesn't really interrupt i can still see
the time behind it so that's neat uh
little lock screen customizations little
status bar improvements you see the
circle battery indicator up here a whole
bunch of awesome stuff and i'm a fan of
it so far so like i said this is just a
quick video in the midst of finals week
i wanted to share with you guys some
neat features of the oneplus one a lot
of people have been asking me about this
phone and i have a lot more to say about
it so expect
probably a couple more videos about this
phone in the coming weeks
but that's been it so far so thanks for
watching feel free to give it a thumbs
up if you enjoyed it or want to see more
like it and i'll talk to you guys in the
next one
peace
you